IT’S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
IT’S YOU TOMORROW NIGHT, I’M
LAURA INGRAHAM THIS IS
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
DEPARTMENT OF HOME SECURITY
WHICH RELEASED SHOCKING NEW
INFORMATION ON CHINESE COVID
COVER UP.
NORMAL CITIZENS ARE MAKING THEIR
VOICES HEARD AND WILL SPEAK TO
ONE TONIGHT.
RAYMOND ARROYO IS HERE WITH THE
LATEST DEVELOPMENTS ON THE THE B
ASSAULT ALLEGATION AND WHY SOME
MIGHT WANT A FORMER FIRST LADY
TO CRASH THE PARTY?
BUT FIRST, MY THOUGHTS ON THE
AMERICAN SHUTDOWN DAY 49.
NOW, WE HAVE BEEN TOLD
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC THAT WE
NEED TO LISTEN TO THE EXPERTS ON
EVERYTHING ON THE LITHOLOGY OF
THE CORONAVIRUS AND THE PROPER
RESPONSE SHOULD BE.
THE TIME AND AGAIN THE EXPERTS
HAVE BEEN WRONG.
ON GENERATE 20 SECONDS, THE
W.H.O. PRAISED CHINA’S GREAT
WORK IN PREVENTING THE SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS.
>> ACTIONS TAKEN IMMEDIATELY.
AND FOLLOWING BY ACTIONS.
IN THE IMPROVEMENT OF THE
PRESIDENT AND HIMSELF WHO GAVE
GUIDANCE.
VERY DIFFERENT FROM PREVIOUSLY,
YOU KNOW, PREVIOUS ACTIONS AND
WE SEEN THAT AND YOU SEE WHAT
THEY ARE COMMITTING.
IN THE VOLUNTEERING, WE SHARE
THAT.
>> Laura: I APPRECIATE THE
DOTS, WELL, THE W.H.O., A COMPLE
AND OTHER DRUG.
OKAY, THEY WERE NEITHER
TRANSPARENT OR SERIOUS IN
PRESENTING THE SPREAD TO OTHER
COUNTRIES AND WE BEEN
DOCUMENTING.
BUT SIX WEEKS LATER, POLITICIANS
BEGAN MAKING CLAIMS THAT WERE
UNTETHERED TO REALITY.
LIKE ON VENTILATORS.
>> ALL THE PROJECTIONS SAY YOU
COULD HAVE AN APEX MEETING
140,000 BEDS AND ABOUT 40,000
VENTILATORS.
WE’RE FOLLOWING THE DATA AND THE
SIGNS AND THAT’S WHAT THE DATA
AND THE SIGN SAYS.
>> Laura: OF COURSE THE DATA
AND A SCIENCE WERE WRONG IN
REALITY, NEW YORK USES ABOUT
25% OF THE TOTAL AND THAT WAS
GOOD NEWS.
ON THE SEVERITY OF THE OUTBREAK
NATIONWIDE TO COME OUT THINGS
LIKE THIS.
>> WE ARE YOUR FUTURE, WE ARE
TODAY, YOU WILL BE IN THREE
WEEKS WERE FOUR WEEKS.
>> Laura: FOLLOWS, IN FACT,
THE ONLY STATE THEY CAME TO
NEW YORK WAS NEW JERSEY.
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY DID NOT
COME CLOSE TO NEW YORK’S
HOSPITALIZATION OR COVID DEATH
IN OTHERS.
WHERE IT TOLD THE SHUTDOWN HAD
TO BE EXTENDED BECAUSE SOCIAL
DISTANCING WAS THE ONLY WAY TO
FIGHT THE VIRUS.
>> Laura: I’M JUST ASKING IF
WE TRY REALLY, REALLY HARD FOR T
NEXT 28 DAYS BECAUSE THEY WILL
MAKE A TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE.
>> JUST KEEP IT UP BECAUSE THIS
IS GOING TO GET US OUT OF IT.
THIS IS OUR BEST AND ONLY GREAT
PUBLIC HEALTH TOOL.
>> Laura: BUT THE FORMER HEAD
OF THE FCA, ADVISOR SCOTT BOSLEY
SPILLED THE BEANS ON SUNDAY.
>> WHILE MITIGATION DOES NOT
FAIL, I THINK IT’S FAIR TO SAY
THAT IT DIDN’T WORK AS WE
EXPECTED.
WE EXPECTED WE WOULD START
SEEING MORE SIGNIFICANT DECLINES
IN NEW CASES AND THAT
SURROUNDING THE NATION AT THIS
POINT.
WE’RE JUST NOT SEEING THAT.
>> Laura: ALTHOUGH INTUITIVELY
I THINK IT PROBABLY SEEMED LIKE
SOCIAL DISTANCING WOULD BE
NECESSARY.
THERE’S NO REAL SCIENTIFIC BASIS
FOR BELIEVING THAT.
IT’S NEVER BEEN STUDIED.
IT WON AN INFECTION SEES THE
DOCTOR TOLD ME LAST WEEK TRYING
TO STOP THE VIRUS LIKE TRYING TO
DRIVE A NAIL THROUGH JELL-O.
VIRUS IS SPREAD, THE OFTEN
WEEKEND AS THEY GO AND LIKES
OURS, WE HOPE IT IS, IT’LL
EVENTUALLY BURN OUT AS FAR AS
DATED.
OPERATIONAL STUDY, NOT YET
PEER-REVIEWED, EXAM AND STAY AT
STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS PREVENTED US
IN WESTERN EUROPE.
COMPARING THE EPIDEMIC BEFORE
AND AFTER THE LOCKDOWN WE DEFINE
NO EVIDENCE OF THE CONTINUITY IN
THE GROWTH RATE DOUBLING TIME
AND REPRODUCTION NUMBERS.
WE PROVIDE ESTIMATES OF THE
DEATH TOLL AND LOCKDOWN POLICIES
AND SHOW THAT THE STRATEGIES
MIGHT NOT HAVE SAVED ANY LIFE IN
WESTERN EUROPE.
WELL, IT’S TRUE.
I SAY IF, THAT WOULD BE STUNNING
STUNNING.
THE AUTHOR ECHOES THE SENTIMENT
OF MICHAEL OF STANFORD
UNIVERSITY.
>> WHAT’S YOUR VIEW OF THE
LOCKDOWN POLICY THAT SO MANY
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES AND STATES IN
AMERICA HAVE USED?
>> I THINK IT’S A HUGE MISTAKE.
I THINK EVERYBODY PANICKED AND
THEY WERE FED INCORRECT NUMBERS
BY EPIDEMIOLOGISTS.
NO DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT WHEN IT
COMES TO THE BACKGROUND OF THIS,
THE DAMAGE DONE BY LOCKDOWN WILL
EXCEED ANY SAVING OF LIVES BY
HUGE FACTOR.
>> Laura: THAT’S WHAT I HEARD
TODAY ON MY OWN DOCTOR’S OFFICE
BECAUSE NO ONE IS THERE.
AS THE PUBLIC WANTS ANSWERS,
SOME OF THE EXPERTS ARE HAILING
THE RESULTS OF NEW EXPENSIVE
DRUG THERAPIES WITH MIDDLING
ACCIDENTS OF SUCCESS BUT MORNING
US AWAY FROM CHEAP GENERIC DRUGS
HAVE ALREADY SAVED
LINES.
IF THE FCA, HATE TO SAY IT, THEY
GOT IT WRONG BIG TIME.
OF COURSE, EVERY DRUG HAS
POTENTIAL SIDE EFFECTS AND
PRESCRIPTION DRUG INTERACTION,
THERE IS MORE THAN EVIDENCE THAT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE SAVES LABS,
SPEED UP RECOVERY TIME, IT CUTS
DOWN ON HOSPITALIZATION.
IT’S ONE OF THE SAFER DRUGS OUT
THERE BY VIRTUE OF THE FACT IT’S
BEEN AROUND FOR 65 YEARS.
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE, THE
ESTEEMED IT TO BE DOWN THE ALLEY
THE TEAM OF COLLEGE EKES
RELEASED THE RESULTS OF HYDROXYL
CHLOROQUINE IN THE 61,000’S.
THE CURE WAS OBTAINED IN 973
PATIENCE WITHIN TEN DAYS.
NO CARDIAC TOXICITY.
IT SHOWED 91% EFFECTIVENESS.
SO WHY IS THE FDA NOT SO MUCH AS
NOTED THE WORKED OF THIS PREMIER
EPIDEMIOLOGIST?
BY THE WAY, CHINESE RESEARCHERS
TO RELEASE THEIR OWN
RETROSPECTIVE STUDY ON FRIDAY
AND THEY FOUND EQUALLY
IMPRESSIVE RESULTS USING
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE IN PATIENTS
WHO WERE SERIOUSLY ILL.
568 PATIENTS CRITICALLY ILL WITH
COVID ALL RECEIVED A BASIC
THERAPY BUT ADDITIONALLY, 48 OF
THEM RECEIVED HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE
7-10 DAYS, 210 MILLIGRAMS, TWICE
PER DAY.
THE TREATMENT WAS ASSOCIATED
WITH DECREASED MORTALITY IN
CRITICALLY ILL PATIENTS OF
COVID-19 THROUGH A ATTENUATION
OF INFLAMMATORY LIDOCAINE STORE
THEM.
THEREFORE IT SHOULD BE
PRESCRIBED FOR TREATMENTS
OF CRITICALLY ILL TO SAVE LIVES.
OKAY, WE CAN SAY CONSIDER THE
SOURCE, IT’S FROM CHINA AND NOT
YET PEER-REVIEWED.
IN A PANDEMIC, AS HE THE
PROFESSOR SAID, LIVES ON THE
LINE AND STILL NO ESTABLISHED
THERAPY OR A VACCINE NOT
EVERYTHING CAN BE PEER-REVIEWED.
EXPERTS ARE NOT ALWAYS RIGHT,
NONE OF US ARE, CAN’T BE, ONCE
INFALLIBLE.
BUT TIMES LIKE THESE, SOMETIMES
WE HAVE TO TAKE YES FOR AN
ANSWER.
NOW, FINALLY, ABOUT THE BAD
MODELS, THE EXPERTS WERE ALL
OVER THE PLACE IN PROJECTING THE
VIRUSES LETHALITY.
>> WERE GOING TO BRING DOWN THE
NUMBER OF INFECTIONS WE DON’T
HAVE 2.2 MILLION DEATHS WERE
1.61 MILLION DEATHS.
>> I WOULD BE SURPRISED IF WE
SAW 100,000 DEATHS IT’S MORE
LIKE THE 60,000 TO THE 100 OR
200,000 DEATHS.
>> Laura: THEY’RE NOT CONFUSED
YET, NOW THEY’RE SAYING THAT
120, 134,000 COULD DIE VALUE
COVID BY AUGUST.
WHAT?
THAT’S DOUBLE WHAT THEY WERE
SAYING A FEW WEEKS AGO SO WHY IS
THIS HAPPENING?
THE EXPERTS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
WASHINGTON DID A LOT OF THE
MODELING.
HE EXPLAINED IT THIS WAY.
>> WE ARE SEEING MANY STATES
REPORTING ON PRESUMPTIVE DEATHS
THAT WERE MISSED IN THE OFFICIAL
DEATH DATA.
NOW, THEY ARE GOING BACK AND
FINDING DEATHS THAT WERE IN
NURSING HOMES AND CARE
FACILITIES AND REPORTING A LARGE
NUMBER OF THE DEATHS ON ANY
GIVEN DAY.
THAT JUST MEANS THAT MORE DEATHS
OCCURRED AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE
EPIDEMIC IS BIGGER.
>> Laura: RETROSPECTIVELY
ADDING DEATHS TO THE COVID
COUNT.
NO WISHES OF ACCURACY.
EXCEPT WE HAD ONE OF THE WORST
INFLUENZA, PNEUMONIA AND SEASONS
AND DECADES.
IT NOT REPORTED VERY OFTEN.
WERE GETTING A FINAL COUNT FROM
THE CDC, BY THE WAY, HAVING
GOTTEN THEM YET.
WELL, THE EXPERTS STRIKE AGAIN.
AND THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS AT THE